hi uh i'm gene smart i'm here with
hannah einbinder and we are taking the
buzzfeed co-star quiz to see how well we
actually know each other i think i'm
going to win i think you worked
nothing about you because you're a woman
me gertie got me
okay so the first question is birthdays
i know that you're september
september november september
and then at this point i'm just throwing
out god
i'm gonna go september
19th
close
september 13th 13th
lucky 13. lucky 13 okay won't forget it
and i have forgotten your birthday
i'm thinking that it was february
unfortunately i am a gemini jean it's
may 21st
we'll say oh that's right it was oh
that's right it's coming up i'm so sorry
honey okay you win i love you no problem
your middle name is elizabeth
very good and your middle name
is walter
yes it's a family name how'd you know my
brain is a sieve i do not remember
middle name what is it it's marie well
the same as the mother did we talk about
that i'm sure probably oh my god well
know yours is elizabeth because i think
i once said that your middle name is
beautiful
and you were like it's elizabeth and i
was like pretty sure it's beautiful
the first time we met would be
screen tests on the sound stage at
paramount for your audition
got that their first job either acting
or not well i know the first play you
were in which was i just know that it
was gay um i don't remember the
it was like it was like
something with blue the word blue in it
right
but it was not
it was not my first fight probably about
my 30th play 30th well wasn't it your um
was it your friend it was my first play
in new york in new york that's why i
remembered it was a person oh no and i
believe your first job was a pole dancer
i prefer
lyrical rhythmic
metallic dancer within the community we
prefer lyrical rhythmic metallic dancer
yeah my first job was
very much the tv show hacks i worked at
a hospital when i was 15 and a half oh
my
and they would show me things and ask me
things that no 15 year old should see or
be asked it was like
oh
i'll go get a nurse excuse me
yeah how did you get that job
you just applied for it
their favorite scene you filmed together
on hacks the interview scene you mean
the scene where we meet for the first
time
yes and i think your favorite scene
that we filmed together
oh our kiss
the dream scene the their giveaway that
they're about to break character and
start laughing it's never happened for
you you've never broken i don't know
that i really i mean i have we're pretty
good about that we wait till they say
cat and then we fall apart yeah yeah
yeah exactly their favorite snack from
crafty one is your favorite candy which
i believe is peanut m m's and i would
say that your favorite snack from crafty
would be tuna and crackers
yes and i'm i don't know if it still is
true but i'm thinking that your favorite
snack from crafty is apple peanut butter
sandwiches you're correct you're still
ahead yeah well i'm obsessed with you so
that helps your dressing room must
have yours better be the blanket i gave
you that's pretty much all i have in
there the only thing i have in my
dressing room is what gene is giving me
i mean i kind of want to say flowers but
i also feel like it's like a comfy
blanket pillow set up well i think it
has to be i have to have the temperature
at a certain level oh of course it needs
to be warm
it keep it really warm people can't
stand to come in there it's like a dry
sauna jean runs so cold it's insane i
mean
hold hands warm heart that's true okay
there go to go to order at a bar i
believe that you are a dirty vodka
martini
yeah or a chardonnay either one but yeah
you don't really drink i don't drink
yeah it would be mirror well i guess
sparkling water hell yeah splash of
pineapple juice
that's like the non-alcoholic fun drink
if you don't drink the mocktail they
call a mocktail their favorite comedy
series of all time
okay i have to say for you because i
don't know i have to say snl
you don't have to lie
if it's not your favorite
you know i get
i guess collectively it might be my
favorite but god i i also count like
spongebob as a comedy series
if we're talking sheer volume of hits i
i might have to even say spongebob which
is kind of okay i lose an element for
you
comedy series not one that i was in
okay well that that's a short list
friends that is like a close second and
it starts with an fr
oh frasier but you're in that oh but
that was just a guest star for a little
bit i'm sorry okay i led you astray
oh i only did like six or seven episodes
okay honor system on god i was thinking
frasier okay now you win you win you get
that one i'm gonna give myself that um
but i was like jeans in it you won an
emmy for it she's like oh i was just on
it for a second you haven't had
okay their favorite swear word is yours
the f-bomb
i think it's probably the c word because
i use it selectively
you gotta save that one but it's a good
one it's one that you use it selectively
and you never use it and then you use it
you really communicate the meaning of
the word i would think so
okay i lose that one too [ __ ]
no i never say that
it's such a terrible word
oh my god what have you ever heard me
say that that's the thing gene doesn't
really swear i say [ __ ]
whisper it
you are so polite finally the actor and
or project that made them want to become
an actor
i don't know i don't know that there is
a pinpoint for either of us i don't know
that there's like a specific one
there's a play i did in high school
ah maybe it's jim carrey i keep talking
about him but i think it probably is
he's like one of the most mind-blowing
performers i've ever experienced i
didn't even without letting you answer
it
i'm sorry
oh god you know what you get that one i
was going to say jim carrey
you honor system i believe you you you
can take that much
so i only got five points okay i got
eight out of twelve look folks let me
just say something right now it's not
about the details it's not about the
historical
you know the dates that this and that
it's about this and this you can't take
a quiz for that's all i'm saying
okay i just can't believe i forgot your
birthday that's terrible no you know
what it's whatever i'm not a big
birthday person anyway so i'm not
running around town screaming about it
we can't air this jean feels i thought
your middle name was ein all this time
oh no
binder
thanks buzzfeed make sure you tune into
the show hacks on hbo max only on your
screen
[Laughter]
i still think hannah walter is cute
you